okay so we are going to test the waters
with Superman Wonder Woman we're gonna
do Volume one the power couple and the
reason why is because Wonder Woman is
amazing that movie is so good I don't
how many of you guys have seen that
movie yet but it is insane god I think
it's probably the best movie that Warner
Brothers has come out with so far with
the DC characters which is solid because
I mean Wonder Woman's never really had
any major silver screen time and I feel
like for her getting yet this is one
heck of a way for us to be able to get
it is god that was amazing
no spoilers I'm not going to spoil
anything for you guys but the movie is
solid so what we're going to do is we're
going to try Superman Wonder Woman vol 1
now if this is something that people
just aren't really interested in then
we'll just drop it after volume 1 and
we'll say hey it was kind of a cool
experiment but if it's something that
people do care about then we'll keep it
going well literally like postpone our
standard DC rebirth stuff and just throw
out a whole bunch of Superman Wonder
Woman because there's only like what is
it like 24 issues before it gets to the
final days of Superman honors so that's
what something like four videos or four
or five videos or some one of those
lines so yeah we're going to test the
waters and we're going to see how this
goes but a Superman and Wonder Woman was
something that actually came out of
Justice League number 12 I think it was
it was a big to do it was the talk of
the town in the come-up a community when
Superman and Wonder Woman kissed and the
reason why is because since like forever
it's been Superman and Lois Lane
it was always Superman and Lois leg it's
never not been Superman and Lois Lane
that's one of the reasons why like new
52 Superman was was like I've kind of
got a you know a mixed review because
people were like and why is he not with
Lois Lane like why is that happening
right now because they're like the
one-two punch of the comic-book
community a Superman Lois Lane we've
been together forever why they're not
together now but this was actually a
really cool bit of fresh air and the
reason why I say that is because it just
makes good sense to have Wonder Woman
and to have Superman together kind of as
like this power couple because they're
just so capable it's like the one thing
that people would always expect to
happen but never really does but again
it also gives us a pretty cool scenario
so in any event the idea here of the
success are really kind of the talk of
the town with regards to Superman and
Wonder Woman kissing led to DC launching
Superman and Wonder Woman and this is
really kind of like a companion to their
own individual stories in the sense that
you had the new 52 Wonder Woman stories
and you had the new 52 Superman stories
but this much like Superman
Batman was designed to be a companion to
their own individual stories it
basically gave us the Adventures of the
two of these characters together off
doing their own thing initially what
this does is it focuses on really the
two of them just kind of being
superheroes you know just kind of
working together working in tandem of
course you got a helicopter this caught
in the midst of a storm and you know
they're they're effectively able to
rescue you know the pilots out of the
helicopter but what we end up finding
out is that this storm is a byproduct of
the rage in the wrath of doomsday now
doomsday being here in the new 52 was
actually kind of interesting because
again this set the stage for Superman
doomed but it was a real quick departure
from what we were used to when it came
to the doomsday character he's only ever
really served one role in DC Comics and
that was to wreck and or kill whoever it
is if he was facing off against that's
the legacy of its character doomsday
will forever will forever be remembered
as the guy who killed Superman and so
because of that people see Doomsday's
arrival on the scene and they're like
okay so I guess we're going to see the
death of Superman or is going to be
severely injured but seeing Wonder Woman
face off against doomsday is actually
pretty incredible because we haven't
really seen that in a consistent basis
we saw it in DC rebirth with Action
Comics rebirth vol 1 but we haven't
really seen Wonder Woman and doomsday
facing off against one another now again
this is kind of cool because Wonder
Woman is not used to a scenario like
this and even after you know Superman is
gone and you know rescue some of these
guys and sort of you know made his way
back one of the things that he basic or
that that Wonder Woman really kind of
says here is she's never faced off
against anybody like doomsday before
it's the idea that she's never been hit
that hard before now just as quickly as
doomsday appears he effectively vanishes
I mean he's gone and we find out that
the reason why is because doomsday is
really supposed to be isolated to the
Phantom Zone
he was basically sent there and so the
whole history of doomsday in terms of as
we know him facing off against Superman
you know killing him so on and so forth
none of that stuff has happened in the
new 52 so the idea here is that doomsday
was created somewhere along the line but
Superman doesn't really know anything
about him and so at this point it's
really just a matter of Wonder Woman and
Superman trying to find a way to
overcome doomsday should they ever have
to confront him again and so what this
does is it leads to Superman being
introduced to Hephaestus and that's one
of the cool aspects of the idea of
Superman and Wonder Woman crossing over
is we basically get to see this kind of
combination of their own individual
worlds merging into one so to speak in
the sense that they cross over into the
other's paths
a Wonder Woman it's all the Greek
mythology it's all of the Greek gods and
goddesses that we know of now keep in
mind BC rebirth came back and basically
changed all this and said that Wonder
Woman has never been back to the mascara
she's never been there before she was
basically going into her own mind
retreating into her own head which begs
the question how does all this fit in
we're just kind of left to believe that
it's sort of there and maybe she's seen
them maybe she's not that's one of the
issues that kind of arises with regards
to what's going on in DC rebirth right
now but the cool thing about this is
that we actually get to see Superman
facing off against some of the gods of
the Greek pantheon now this is something
that DC is really sort of hearkened out
when it comes to their own godly
landscape in the sense of the Greek
mythological gods have been introduced
time and time again and DC Comics and
we've seen Superman face off against
them in different iterations but in the
new 52 one of the big things that was
done was to basically make these gods
tangible instead of saying well they
come from this whole you know other
plane of existence they're over there in
no-man's land kind of out left field and
nobody ever meets your talks to them
bringing them into the fold meant that
we can now see Superman face off against
them we can basically get this sort of
litmus test on where Superman stands in
relation to them now in terms of just
raw strength raw ability the gods take
the cake almost every single time but in
this instance Apollo the god of the Sun
literally blasts Superman with solar
energy in an attempt to take him out
and this basically supercharges Superman
and so what this does is it leads to
Superman is kind of you know using these
enhanced abilities to effectively go
toe-to-toe with Apollo and really kind
of establishes dominance of the fact
that he's not a guy who's easily walked
over so again it's really just kind of
DC saying here is where Superman resides
in relation to the Greek gods and
goddesses of the Pantheon that Wonder
Woman is used to you know of Olympus and
so on now from here we basically pick up
with the introduction of General Zod and
this is really kind of interesting
because this is the Superman aspect of
his own landscape sort of rolling over
into this but the other half of the
scenario is the Justice League of
America at least I believe that's the
case and the Justice League of America
was kind of this weird situation with
regards to the new 52 and the reason why
I say that is we've had this discussion
several times we'll have it again once
we talk about the Justice League in the
new 52 when we get around to their whole
run but the idea was that you know after
crisis on Infinite Earths
DC got rid of the traditional Justice
League as we knew them and they replaced
it with Justice League International now
Justice League International was
basically kind of a
hodgepodge of people of superheroes who
could normally never sell their own
books and so as a result it was like a
team led by Batman Batman was thrown
onto the team in order to beef up a
reason for fans to go out and read the
story in the first place but it had a
lot of character interactions that we
would never really see with the new 52
the Justice League of America was kind
of this second-tier team to the Justice
League and so the Justice League was
Batman Wonder Woman Superman the flash
Green Lantern so on and so forth the
Justice League of America was really
more of like another name for a group
called Argus the Advanced Research Group
uniting superheroes and so Argus was
basically just you know a
government-sanctioned
superhero team and that's essentially
what the Justice League of America was
it was basically a government-funded
superhero team that kind of functioned
somewhat as a companion to the
traditional Justice League just not
really seen on the same level and so
again what this does is it actually
brings in Martian Manhunter as well as
Hawkman and a handful of others who have
basically been tasked to figure out
what's going on was regards to the
arrival of this strange being on earth
this person is kind of disturbance to
the middle east which of course we know
to be General Zod now of course because
General Zod is basically a Kryptonian
he's easily able to overpower the
Justice League of America which results
in Superman and Wonder Woman basically
responding and then investigating on
their own now of course with them
showing up on the scene it creates a
little bit of tension it actually
creates tension with Steve Trevor and
the reason why this creates tension with
his character is because of the fact
that Steve Trevor was basically Wonder
Woman's introduction to the remaining
superhero community kind of introduction
to the world outside of the mascara and
there was a very strong romance between
the two of them so at this point it's
really kind of like jealousy more so
than anything else with a sense of Steve
Trevor not really being able to be in a
relationship with Wonder Woman now of
course Steve Trevor would go on to play
a pretty significant role in DC Comics
during the story of Darkseid war and
Justice League but nonetheless you know
Wonder Woman using their lasso of truth
again forces General Zod to basically
tell the truth reveal his name is being
Zod so on and so forth revealed a few
more things here and there but
ultimately the idea is a Superman
basically takes him as a prisoner of
sorts and throws him in the fortress of
solitude kind of keeping him in stasis
now the reason for this is because of
the fact that no one really knows
anything about Zod Superman doesn't know
anything about Zod so the idea is to
basically keep him confined until
Superman can come back and begin asking
questions again now of course
also kind of brings into play the idea
of Superman and Wonder Woman having
their own romance so that's really cool
the way this was done the reason being
because of the fact that they basically
get their own personal gift or at least
Wonder Woman gives a gift to Superman
and what she does is she gives him the
gift of time now this is not a literal
gift of time where she does it she
basically went to Batman and a flash and
said hey take care of things you know as
far as the Justice League is concerned
for a little while Superman and I are
going to have some alone time we're
going to have some us time but so again
it's kind of cool because what it does
is it allows them to kind of build on
their relationship and that's really the
nature of the two of them having their
own story one of the biggest issues they
face there's much like any kind of
superhero couple that's out there one of
the biggest issues they have when it
comes to you their friendship you know
when it comes to other superheroes who
have an actual relationship is trying to
maintain that relationship with that
friendship in the face of constantly
facing off against threats and that's
really the issue that Wonder Woman and
Superman deal with here is they can't
really flesh out their own individual
relationship because there's constantly
an enemy to deal with there's constantly
a threat against the earth
there's constantly something that
requires the attention of them or the
Justice League that keeps them from
being able to actually be a legitimate
couple now the other half of this is
that they had basically tried to keep
the relationship secret really for the
sake of just kind of the team's own
posterity as well as their own you know
individual privacy but the idea here is
that someone somewhere had basically
reached this information out and the
whole world has become aware of the fact
that Wonder Woman and Superman are
together now at this point it becomes
the talk of the town I mean everybody
begins you know having this discussion
now at this point we switch back over to
Superman having us conversation with
General Zod really the biggest question
that Superman has for Zod is who is
doomsday what do you know about doomsday
the reason why this question is being
asked as opposed to give me everything
about yourself is because at the moment
Dada is effectively in a prison of sorts
so it really allows Superman to kind of
prioritize questions and say hey look
our immediate threat right now is this
doomsday creature once we learn about
that then we'll come back and won't
worry about General Zod now of course
Zod uses this to his own advantage in
the sense that because he speaks
Kryptonian Superman has basically given
him the keys to his own prison all this
technology all this stuff is based on
the Kryptonian language the Kryptonian
physiology General Zod using his
Kryptonian language basically frees
himself and in the process begins to go
through and sort
to attack Superman but the ultimate goal
here is to basically free one of his
lieutenants from the Phantom Zone now
again this is kind of cool because what
this does is it begins the process or
sort of fleshing out the nature of
Superman and Wonder Woman and what it is
they're doing together in terms of them
being a superhero and having to fight a
common enemy now initially this kind of
jumps back for a second to the idea of
Wonder Woman spending time on sin
mascara but once she leaves you know
once she basically you know leads to
mascara and goes back out into the world
again she's immediately contacted by
Batman who basically says look
Superman's under attack you have to go
to his aid now this is kind of cool
because remember these are Kryptonians
you know once they're exposed to the Sun
and once their powers begin to develop
once the insanity of being stuck in the
Phantom Zone wears off on Faora then now
it's basically you know Superman in a
super woman fighting against Superman he
cannot do this on his own and this is
the intrinsic value of the relationship
between Wonder Woman and Superman it's
the fact that they basically complement
one another they work very well with one
another because remember Wonder Woman
was always kind of viewed as this
character who was in a lot of ways equal
to Superman and in some instances more
capable than Superman this was one of
the big discussion points when it came
to like the whole topic of Justice
League of America the Tower of Babel
when Ra's al Ghul had gotten ahold of
the safety protocols that Batman had on
the Justice League in terms of how to
defeat each individual member of the of
the league Wonder Woman was a warrior
who would continually fight she would
never stop until her enemy was defeated
even if it meant fighting to her own
death and that was sort of carried over
in the new 52 she's just as capable just
as dangerous as Superman but because of
the fact that she is a born-and-bred
warrior as opposed to Superman be more
of a guy with insane amounts of power
who is effectively peaceful if it came
down to it Wonder Woman could kill him
just because of the fact that she would
refuse to stop fighting whereas Superman
would try to talk things out or kind of
keep things in order and so in light of
the fact that Faora and General Zod are
as powerful as Superman and Wonder Woman
but they're basically born and bred
warriors what this does is it leads to
them engaging in a retreat now again
this new 52 suit ran this younger
version of Superman was more brash she
wasn't as wise and experienced as the
classic Superman that we see in DC
rebirth right now and so because of that
it was really kind of up to Wonder Woman
to sort of call this retreat it was
really
call us saying we have to go back and we
have to regain various arms and armament
we have to find a way to be able to take
these guys out because we can't beat
them with our brute force alone and so
of course they end up travelling to a
festus you basically make some armor for
them which in turn they use to attack
Zod and peor now of course they're able
to hold their own pretty successfully in
the sense they're able to basically
channel the energy they've absorbed
through punches kind of channel them
back at a General Zod and Paora the
problem with this is that Apollo
eventually decides to get involved just
out of sheer curiosity just because of
the fact that at this point he's not
really not really a huge fan of Superman
but also because of the idea they just
kind of want to see what happens so what
they do is they actually bombard they or
in General Zod with sunlight which in
turn supercharges them in the same way
that Superman had been supercharged
earlier so again this is cool this is a
great moment to kind of see these
characters sort of band together as a
great moment to see Superman and Wonder
Woman continually facing off against a
threat that shows themselves to
constantly overpower the two of them now
from here things with General Zod and
Superman and Wonder Woman and so on they
in pretty quick I mean they're pretty
simple in terms of how they unfold the
overarching goal here of General Zod was
to basically open a portal to the war
world and then basically bring the
armies of world world in to earth now
this is one of the issues when it comes
to General Zod in the new 52 is because
they basically revamped his origin but
his origin in terms of how he was
depicted doesn't really have a whole lot
to do with what his motivations are here
what we know with his origin is that he
basically was a guy who he was a young
kid who watched his parents killed by a
group called the char when they were
stuck in a jungle ultimately he was
saved by jor-el which eventually led to
him basically becoming a soldier but he
always harbored a hatred for the charge
so we basically manufactured a war his
treachery was discovered by jor-el and
then in turn he was locked in the
Phantom Zone for trying to instigate
conflict where none previously existed
but in truth his motivation here isn't
fully fleshed out it's just he's here
and for whatever reason he wants to see
the earth conquered by war well we're
not really given a motivation as to why
we're not really told what the purpose
is behind this what is kind of told
that's what it is that's going on here
so it's one of those small weaknesses
that sort of takes place in the story
but overall again the Wonder Woman
Superman story is really designed it is
kind of underscore the nature of the two
characters in the sense that they make
whatever sacrifices are necessary in
order to achieve their overarching
goal which is to basically stay a
superhero couple and save the world as
best they can and that's ultimately the
decision they come to when they're
basically stuck inside of a nuclear
reactor when they're kind of just
dropped in there by General Zod and by
say or now of course the idea of Zod is
that by being inside of a nuclear
reactor solar energy simply won't
penetrate that you know for whatever
reason the radiation surrounded the act
of the reactor will keep solar energy
from coming inside of it and keeping
Superman empowered which means he'll
effectively become weaker the radiation
itself will basically kill Wonder Woman
now the idea here is that because this
is a reactor all they have to really do
is just kind of detonated in the same
way that you would detonate a nuclear
bomb just a massive amount of energy
that's unleashed which in turn would
destroy the nuclear reactor but severely
damages Superman but kind of leaves
Wonder Woman intact now the reason for
this is because of the fact that Wonder
Woman is shielded from the blasts from
the main blast itself now again this
really kind of highlights the inherent
weakness of Wonder Woman in the sense
that where she is very strong where she
is very capable she can still be hurt
that's one of the kind of back-and-forth
things when it comes to her character
you know the question being asked you
know if she's impervious to bullets then
why would she need to block them with
her bracers you know where they're
little bracelets but if she is pervious
to bullets then surely something like a
nuclear to clear explosion would kill
her the clothing of Superman wouldn't be
enough to protect her again there's a
little bit of credulity that kind of
gets stretched in this little bit of a
story but the purpose is served here the
fact is that ultimately General Zod and
Faora are basically reckon find to the
Phantom Zone again due to their
explosion now that's one of the other
world kid bits here one of the other
little issues that takes places because
we're not explicitly told how they're
confined back to the Phantom Zone we're
just kind of told that they are so again
it gives us this story and then just
kind of wraps up without a lot of
questions being answered here so
ultimately because of the damage that
was sustained by Superman what little
energy he has left basically allows them
to kind of fly into the presence of the
Sun to be imbued directly with his solar
radiation which in turn heals him and
then from here it's a matter of turning
their attention to Hestia of the Amazons
now again the reason why this is done is
because of the fact that Hestia is one
of the various women who are of the
Amazon race who have taken up residence
within mainstream society itself she's
basically part of the main group now
she's also the one who would leaked the
information of Wonder Woman and Superman
being together in the first place out
into the public sphere so she's really
the reason behind a lot of this
stuff but the fact remains because she
is of Amazonian heritage because she's
the trainer and healer of Wonder Woman
she's the best person to take care of
Wonder Woman anyway now of course this
also basically see Superman going off to
his fortress of solitude and being
healed you know by the by the Kryptonian
PLA matrix and so on and so forth but
again what this does is it sort of sets
the stage for the idea of doomsday
coming back in the sense of doomsday is
basically reawakened you know after the
first skirmish she destroys a submarine
and that's really about it it's just a
stage for Superman doomed but again this
really was designed to kind of focus on
the nature of Superman and Wonder Woman
that as a power couple as the two most
popular superheroes in terms of a man
and a woman in DC Comics they really
kind of go together almost perfect it
really just kind of makes good sense to
put them together and have them become a
couple it's also this idea that because
they're so capable because they're so
durable each one can stand the other in
a multitude of ways so again it's really
kind of just designed to highlight these
two things to bring these two characters
together and ask the question what kind
of escapades and adventures can Superman
and Wonder Woman get up to if the two of
them are working together as a superhero
team what would happen he said guys
we're go ahead and bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the Rob or if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and let me know how you
guys feel about the whole Wonder Woman
you know Superman thing let me know what
you guys feel about this these line of
stories again I'm just kind of testing
the waters here so if there's something
that you guys enjoy then let me know you
know and we'll go ahead and keep it
going but if some people don't care
about then we'll just go ahead and go
back to our regularly scheduled DC
viewer stuff so anyway guys we're going
to go ahead and bring this to an end and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]